[Music]
guys welcome to coffees hello welcome to
another way you can lose a thousand
dollars today we're talking about Caleb
Maddox highly requested video you know
the guy's older now he's selling a brand
new course the whitey a method is it
worth it isn't a scam we're gonna find
out you could profit from YouTube
without being a youtuber we're even
spending a single dime on YouTube ads
and imagine you do that well than ever
step in front of a camera ever showing
your face ever editing even a single
video and without being good at
technology at all already hot off the
gate with some wild promises apparently
this whitey method involves you being a
youtuber without doing anything that
usually comes with being a youtuber but
he goes on in pitches hard every lose
you guys know anything about your TV I
said what cube it's not everything that
goes into it that bad yes well yeah
that's what went into it
with the old way but now there was a new
way and that new way is called the
whitey a method I really believe that
the whitey method is the greatest
opportunity of our ok big promises here
the greatest opportunity of our era I'll
be the judge of that
ok Caleb don't be making such a wild
promises here so what is the whitey a
method ahead to join Caleb's webinar to
find out
so one of the first things we're told in
this webinar is hey this isn't a kids
game here's the deal people are leaving
so much money on the table by thinking
YouTube is just for kids
sure Caleb Maddox faked that ten
thousand dollar sales call when he was
14 if you if you hadn't Caleb a ten
thousand dollar check called you a 100
thousand dollar check
would you end up doing this Dale shirt
he was a bit cringy back then whenever
there's a traffic jam I don't get
worried but that is all behind him now
that's the old Caleb or the young Caleb
now he's older and he's was in fact he's
so wise that he posted a video called
this one video is more valuable than
four years of college without ever going
to college did you know I'm smart you
have to be to make a video like that to
know that a video is more valuable than
four years of college having never gone
to college I feel like this is maybe the
most important thing I think this
honestly maybe till we die out of every
podcast we ever do this might be I will
show you everything I've ever gotten in
my entire life everything - five words
that were gonna say today just five
words and what that video boils down to
are five steps that are apparently more
valuable than a Harvard education number
one you have to desire never to you have
to ask number three faith number four so
number five reap boom saved you four
years right there and Caleb wants you to
know that he's not gonna risk his
reputation with a quick cash grab on
this no no no no no no I refuse to risk
my reputation I'm not gonna sit here and
tell you guys anything I do not fully
believe I'm not gonna sit here and tell
you guys something that's just kind of a
little bit twisted a little bit out of
integrity he's a hundred percent optical
he wants you to know that his mentors
are watching and list of my mentors are
on here and soon after this we learned
that the mysterious whitey method we've
been hearing so much about
from this new Caleb Maddox new and
improved older wiser Caleb Maddox is
YouTube automation that is the new way
that is YouTube's automation that's
right
why create content yourself when you can
let someone else create it for you and
blow up your channel and make all this
money now you might look at Caleb
maddux's channel
say hey this guy only has 25 kgs
subscribers after being on the platform
for eight years I mean how is this guy
gonna make me a full-time income on
YouTube well Caleb brought in a guru
sort of a guru to the Guru his name is
Deb it
I met this dude who's become a close
friend of mine his name is Devin made me
at 401 YouTube channel that's what he
showed me two more channels that were
making it money everyone and his dozens
of channels are fully automated its
Devin you'll be learning from but
curiously enough caleb never mentions
his last name or what kind of channels
Devin has automated he shows a lot of
screenshots of Devin making all this
money but never actually tells us what
type of channel it is or what types of
videos they are so how is Devin making
all this money what kind of niche is he
in well that's where yours truly had to
put in a lot of footwork I would look
for you I will find you and thanks to my
proprietary guru research formula I
finally found him I basically just
searched up his name in fat ass
Instagram and matched up the pictures
and do you know what you find when you
find who Devin really is you find that
Devin also doesn't want you to know what
his YouTube channels are but luckily
there's a youtube video talking about
all the money he makes and showing all
his channels and he's trying to gray out
the information but someone slipped up
on the editing site here and maybe it's
because you paid a guy $5 on Fiverr to
edit the whole thing I mean that's the
whole idea he probably automated the
video and it doesn't exactly give you a
quality product so we will be the
beneficiaries of where the editor
slipped up so we can finally unveil what
the hidden niche is what the big secret
is all about what is the greatest
opportunity of our are you ready are you
ready drumroll please okay prepare
yourself greatest income opportunity of
our generation red if it is like you
know where people repost content from
reddit to YouTube
that type of video yeah it's the
opportunity of our era and not like you
reddit videos like PewDiePie does you
know where they comment or make jokes
about reddit posts
no no nothing transformative we're
talking about text-to-speech the laziest
possible reddit videos where the whole
reddit post is read by a robot
ex-inmates of Reddit what was the
stupidest thing you've seen a new inmate
do on his first day in prison that's the
income opportunity sorry sorry we're
supposed to be taking this very
seriously Caleb Maddox is a serious guy
the greatest opportunity of our full
ethics ful he's got ethics I refuse to
risk my reputation I'm not gonna sit
here and tell you guys anything I do not
fully believe okay
ethics he wouldn't sell on a thousand
dollar product if it wasn't a top-notch
product I'm not gonna sit here and tell
you guys something which is kind of a
little bit twisted a little bit out of
integrity so we're supposed to be taking
this seriously the greatest income
opportunity of our generation it's not
Amazon it's not sales it's not computer
coding it's not going to college okay
you can watch a youtube video more
valuable in college the greatest income
opportunity of our generation are
text-to-speech reddit videos that's just
the truth it's just the truth okay
Caleb Maddox would know you guys guys
this is not some great opportunity this
is just a way to create lazy content to
try to cheat the system while you can
but the shelf life of this stuff is
always short already Devin is having
monetization problems which Caleb
conveniently forgets to mention there
was this one we ran into a big issue he
got do you monetize and of course I
can't speak to exactly why I don't know
exactly why he's having problems but
it's probably because in 2019 YouTube
made a change to their monetization
rules where text-to-speech robot voices
are now against their Terms of Service
which means that basically all of the
videos that this guy has profited from a
lot of them are now unmonitored but at
least the ones we know it look you may
make a little bit money but you probably
won't usually by the time you guys hear
of this the real opportunity has dried
up and now let's go back to Caleb who's
been promoting all this stuff is some
miracle source of income
he's reselling the obvious idea of
reddit copy pasta that you outsource in
fiber and up work and then he's selling
that for nine hundred ninety seven
dollars a thousand dollars to people who
don't know any better who to people who
don't know that a lot of this
opportunity has already dried up to
people who trust that when somebody like
Caleb says with so much confidence and I
could say that with full integrity I can
say that boldly and feel like I'm
completely ethical they think he means
it they assume he means it and it's just
scummy and I think look I mean to be
honest with you guys
I think in some ways it's not Caleb's
fault Caleb Maddox is like the bane of
the motivational guru space unlike other
gurus who adopted the hype the fall
sales pitches in advertising Caleb was
born in this since a baby he was raised
in this insane motivational world where
false promises and overhyped results are
the norm not the exception so maybe it
shouldn't be a shock to us that he faked
a $10,000 phone call maybe it shouldn't
be a shock that he's passing off reddit
videos as the opportunity of our era
he's the product of a world that cares
about image over substance that cares
about shortcuts over long-term success
and believes that advertising shouldn't
be held accountable for what it promises
but guys have no fear in the end in the
darkest of days
about here I might be you if you joined
coffee Zyliss Fagor of course a 111
million dollars value for only 997
dollars this offer will not last long so
join now now now you didn't think I'd
forget about this course did you the
only thing to do in order to register
for my webinar is like subscribe and
click the link in the description to
lock in your seat it's not a limited and
I can guarantee that this webinar will
be more valuable than four years of
college you're welcome
this offer will last for the next four
seconds too late
[Music]
but never to the trust